A dog and a cat got into a spat.
Now, what do you think the cat thought of that?
The dog chased the cat through a field of flowers.
They ran, and they ran for hours and hours.
The dog chased the cat through deep, deep mud.
His hair and her fur were covered with crud.
The cat leapt over a wall with a dash.
But over the wall came the dog in a flash.
And into the water went the cat with a splash.
The cat swam quickly from shore to shore.
The dog swam behind to chase her some more.
The cat crawled out and shook off the water.
The dog kept swimming as fast as an otter.
The cat ran through the tall grass of a meadow.
The dog that chased her was one angry fellow.
She hid under a car with her tail sticking out.
But the dog found her there, after looking about.
From under the car the cat ran like a shot.
She ran into a ditch, hoping not to get caught.
But the dog followed after.
The ditch stopped him not.
The chase then finally came to a stop.
The cat climbed a tree straight up to the top.
The dog just sat beneath her and growled.
The cat had escaped.
The dog sat there and howled.